foreign every morning when the fishing
boats return
Market in Port Sudan comes alive
on display a curious variety of the
bounties from the Red Sea it's the
busiest time for fish Traders
an upbeat mood prevails
but behind the cheerfulness there's
stories of hardships I bring my catch
from a beach 200 kilometers away from
here I pay for ice fuel transportation
and the handlers the heat in July and
August slows down our work the benefit
is small
despite the scorching summer heat the
fishermen still get a good catch but
it's the High Cost of Living that's
hitting hard eighty-year-old Muhammad
artega has been a fisherman since he was
12. now retired he's still involved in
the fish trade
the war has surely affected us there's
no cash the purchasing power is weak and
even when you sell well you fill your
hands with Ash it has no value due to
the High Cost of Living
the conflict has also harmed fish
exports says this Trader from Tunisia
who used to send shipments to Jordan and
Saudi Arabia now he just settles in the
local markets at the beach sits some old
and young men who say they don't go
fishing anymore
but they still stick to the Sea hoping
the situation may change Khan
before 2018 and 2019 things were
different fuel was subsidized fishermen
were supported the price of fish was
good returns from one fishing trip were
no less than 250 dollars now all of that
is gone
this may look like a graveyard of boats
but in fact all of these boats are
functioning only the fishermen are
saying that they haven't put them to Sea
for years simply because it's not worth
the effort
it cost a lot for Mubarak to build his
own boat
before he realized the scale of the
crisis now his boat is gathering dust
while he works as a welder elsewhere to
make ends meet
trying at the same time as he says to
keep alive the spark of his love
for the soft soothing waves of the scene
Al Jazeera or Sudan